neue corona beschlüsse mindest bußgelder
für masten verweigerer verschärfte
regeln für urlauber in risikogebieten
aber keine einheitliche regelung für
private feiern eskalation nach
polizeigewalt in wisconsin wird ein
17-jähriger wegen doppelmordes angeklagt
der us spitzensport steht aus protest
gegen rassismus still und am gipfel
keine ruhe vor 200 jahren gelang die
erstbesteigung der zugspitze und wies
damit den weg zum heutigen
massentourismus
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind den sport in der sendung
präsentiert norbert leben und mein
schönes land formiert
wir beginnen mit den neuen corona regeln
weil die infektionszahlen aktuell so
deutlich steigen trotz sommer und viel
draußen sein und weil das
ansteckungsrisiko im herbst wieder
wachsen wird plädierte die
bundeskanzlerin für einheitliche und
schärfere beschränkungen konnte aber
nicht alle ministerpräsidenten
überzeugen
geeinigt hat man sich auf folgendes
rückkehrer aus risikogebieten müssen
möglichst ab erster oktober mindestens
fünf tage in quarantäne
großveranstaltungen ohne hygiene konzept
werden bis ende des jahres verboten
und wer gegen die masken pflicht
verstößt muss außer in sachsen anhalt
mit einem bußgeld von mindestens 50 euro
rechnen
das boot hat details allein dass sich
die kanzlerin nach über zwei monaten
wieder mit den ministerpräsidenten
austausch zeigt dass die
verantwortlichen dringenden
handlungsbedarf sehen so zum beispiel
bei reisen in risikogebiete
hier werden die maßnahmen drastisch
verschärft der aber eine vermeidbare
reise in ein schon vor reiseantritt
feststehen das risikogebiet antritt da
wollen wir die rechtliche regelung zu
treffen das ist heute im
infektionsschutzgesetz nicht angelegt
aber da wollen wir die regierung zu
treffen dass dafür kein kompensation
mehr des verdienstausfalls möglich sein
wird wer gegen die quarantäne verstößt
muss künftig mit bußgeldern rechnen
ebenso bei nichteinhaltung der masken
pflicht wir haben jetzt gerade ein quasi
bußgeld im öffentlichen nahverkehr
bereits eingeführt wenn denn das erhöhte
beförderungsentgelt aber jetzt kommen
wir mit diesem hoheitlichen bußgeld
natürlich auch ein stück härter daher
und ich glaube das zeigt dass wir in
deutschland ist sehr ernst nehmen
doch hier endet auch schon die einheit
der länder sachsen anhalt lehnt ein
mindestbußgeld für masken verweigere ab
und auch eine obergrenze bei
familienfeiern wird es nicht bundesweit
geben beschwichtigung
wir werden in den ländern die roadshow
bei dem 100 thema angekündigt worden
noch unterschiedliche akzente haben das
hat mit infektionsgeschehen zusammen
sondern was trotzdem wichtig ist der
geist heute wieder die gemeinsame
philosophie die war spürbar die spiegelt
sich auch in einem sehr ausführlichen
text wieder kritik kommt von der afg
siehe die neuen maßregeln schlicht für
überflüssig aus unserer sicht sind diese
maßnahmen in gänze nicht verhältnismäßig
die regierung haben kein beleg vorgelegt
dafür dass diese maßnahmen notwendig
sind das die geeignet und erforderlich
wären für bund und länder dagegen sind
die neuen beschlüsse das signal dass sie
ein weiteres anwachsen der infektionen
unbedingt verhindern wollen
der theo koll in berlin bei feiern zu
hause war eigentlich eine einheitliche
begrenzung geplant nicht mehr als 25
leute warum gab es da keine einigung
und offensichtlich weil es von vielen
ministerpräsidenten als ein zu
weitgehender eingriff in die
privatsphäre und den private freiheiten
gesehen wurde
in sachsen-anhalt beispielsweise ist die
zahl der infektionen der vergangenen
tage nur ein bruchteil von denjenigen in
bayern deswegen hat sich der dortige
ministerpräsident haseloff strikt
dagegen ausgesprochen und vielleicht
spielt es auch eine rolle dass dort im
kommenden jahr landtagswahlen sind und
die afg massiv auf das thema setzt dass
der staat angeblich die pandemie nutze
um die bürger zu bevormunden
der wunsch nach einer
teilnehmerbegrenzung bei privaten feiern
war im wesentlichen jahr getrieben von
den aktuellen studienergebnissen die
gezeigt haben dass einer der zentralen
orte für ansteckungen das eigene zuhause
ist und eben private feiern aber damit
konnte sich die kanzlerin heute sondern
doch nicht durchsetzen vielen dank
berlin für diese einschätzung theo koll
weiter keine großveranstaltungen
mindestens fünf tage quarantäne für
reise rückkehrer aus risikogebieten die
neuen core ohne regeln lösen
unterschiedliche reaktionen aus anton
kuschelten fasst zusammen
frankfurt am main heute nachmittag die
innenstadt brechend voll wer künftig in
der u bahn oder im bus ohne maske
erwischt wird muss mindestens 50 euro
strafe zahlen
also ich denke wenn die menschen
von sich selbst aus dazu in der lage
sind das die masken pflicht einzuhalten
dann ist es leider so muss man sie
zwingen absolute freiheitsberaubung
durchsichtig ist und die maske am
flughafen der mainmetropole landeten
heute einige maschinen aus
risikogebieten wie mallorca viele
passagiere wussten da noch gar nichts
von den verschärften quarantänemaßnahmen
geht nicht fünf tage in quarantäne
ich finde das richtig weil wenn das bis
jetzt niemand niemand auffassen würde
dann hätten wir wahrscheinlich weisen
der explosionsartige vermehrung dieser
infizierten menschen weniger tests mehr
quarantäne die luftfahrtbranche
kritisiert die neuen corona maßnahmen
die geplante verschärfung der
quarantänebestimmungen ab oktober wurden
faktisch zu einem erneuten lockdown des
gesamten reise geschehen zu führen und
deswegen kommt es jetzt darauf an test
kapazitäten aufzubauen um genau das zu
vermeiden
auch für die veranstaltungsbranche keine
guten nachrichten die meisten großevents
bleiben verboten mindestens bis ende des
jahres und das wird wohl konsequenzen
haben veranstaltungswirtschaft insgesamt
ist seit fast sechs monaten ohne
einnahmen ohne jegliche umsätze und
dementsprechend ist die lage
katastrophal dann ist eine pleitewelle
impliziert und vorherbestimmt düstere
aussichten also die sich frühestens im
nächsten jahr wieder aufhellen werden
mehr zum thema gleich hier im anschluss
im zdf spezial corona krisengipfel im
kanzleramt und wenn sie nochmal
nachlesen wollen welche neuen krone
regeln wann und wo genau gelten
dann können sie das in aller ruhe tun
unsere zelte erfreute app gibt einen
überblick über die neuen maßnahmen
die bundesregierung stellt weiterhin
viele milliarden bereit um kleine und
große unternehmen über die korona zeit
zu retten
anfangs hat das offenbar ganz gut
geklappt mit den soforthilfen bei den
sogenannten überbrückungshilfen
allerdings zeigt sich dass bislang nur
ein äußerst geringer teil des geldes
geflossen ist woran das liegt zeigt
allerdings parade
led licht installationen für messen und
großevents das spezialgebiet der kölner
firma schnickschnack noch halten sie
sich aus eigener kraft ohne staatliche
hilfen über wasser fragt sich nur wie
lange noch beantragt aber wir schließen
das nicht mehr aus also anfang des
jahres haben wir gedacht vielleicht
kommen wir drum rum
doch nun dauert die krise an deshalb
glaubt der bundeswirtschaftsminister
heute in köln noch einmal für staatliche
hilfen unter anderem für die
verlängerung der überbrückungshilfen und
es ist jetzt möglich mit die
überbrückungshilfen und die wir jetzt
verlängert haben für september oktober
november dezember
es ist jetzt möglich dass ein
mittelständischer unternehmer bis zu
50.000 euro im monat bekommen für
tatsächlich entfallen anstehende
fixkosten nur bislang werden diese
hilfen kaum genutzt aus dem 25
milliarden euro topf sind bislang nur
700 millionen euro abgerufen worden
der aufwand die gelder abzurufen ist
sehr sehr hoch und als unternehmer muss
ich eine langfristige und sichere
planungs möglichkeit haben und kritiker
wie die bonitätsprüfer von creditreform
warnen vor zu viel staatlicher hilfe wir
sind auf jeden fall die gefahr dass
unternehmen die eigentlich gar nicht
wegen kronen schieflage gekommen sind
von diesen maßnahmen profitieren die von
der bundesregierung gerade weiterhin
geschlossen wurden die schockstarre zu
beginn der korona krise ist längst
verflogen die kritischen stimmen zur
wirtschaftspolitik der bundesregierung
sie werden immer lauter
die gegner der korona politik hatte es
angekündigt jetzt ist der widerspruch
damit einem eilantrag wollen sie das
demonstrationsverbot des berliner senats
kippen
die veranstaltung ist für samstag
geplanten mit einer juristischen
entscheidung ist spätestens morgen zu
rechnen
der blick auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen zeigt wenig veränderungen im
durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
wurden hierzulande täglich 1330
ansteckungen neu gemeldet gestern waren
es 1350 die nato mahnt moskau sich in
belarus zurückzuhalten generalsekretär
stoltenberg sagte russland solle die
souveränität des landes respektieren wie
es auch die nato
zuvor hatte der russische präsident
putin seine bereitschaft erklärt
notfalls dem umstrittenen staatschef
lukaschenko beizustehen
russland halte sicherheitskräfte bereit
die bei einer zuspitzung der lage helfen
können in die usa zu den schüssen der
polizei auf einen schwarzen
familienvater im kino wisconsin und die
voll
ein 17 jähriger wurde festgenommen er
soll am rande einer protestaktion zwei
menschen erschossen haben und gegen
rassismus und polizeigewalt haben nun
auch us profi sportler ein zeichen
gesetzt sie weigerten sich anzutreten
boykott im basketball baseball und
fußball
das gab es so noch nie peter jäger keine
krawalle keine gewalt in der vergangenen
nacht in kinos wisconsin
der protest blieb weitgehend friedlich
nachdem die lage in der nacht zuvor so
eskaliert war und ein 17-jähriger zwei
menschen getötet hatte der war bewaffnet
durch die straßen gelaufen als mitglied
einer selbsternannten bürgerwehr die
meinte die stadt vor wütenden
demonstranten schützen zu müssen
der junge mann schießt danach läuft er
mit erhobenen händen richtung polizei
die ergreift ihn erst wesentlich später
in den sozialen medien präsentiert er
sich als waffen fan
wir müssen sicherstellen dass wir die
spaltung diese wut stoppen die gerade in
diesem land herrscht und das beginnt
damit dass jeder von uns den willen hat
ehrlich miteinander zu reden
auslöser der proteste ein polizeieinsatz
am vergangenen sonntag noch immer ist
unklar warum die beamten jacob black mit
gezogener waffe verfolgten und ihn an
seinem auto mindestens 7
in den rücken geschossen die polizisten
sind beurlaubt
in den us profi ligen setzten zahlreiche
sportler mit einem beispiellosen boykott
ein zeichen gegen polizeigewalt die nbl
verschiebt basketballspiele auch
baseballer tennis und fußball spieler
wollen nicht mehr auf den platz
wir fordern gerechtigkeit für jacob
black und dass die polizisten zur
verantwortung gezogen werden während der
republikanische partei tag läuft
entsendet us-präsident tram
bundespolizisten nach canossa law and
order recht und gesetz ist seine
botschaft im wahlkampf die situation
haben es gesehen über das konzert war
auch thema beim parteitag der
republikaner
zunächst war wie erwartet vizepräsident
mike pence für eine weitere amtszeit
nominiert worden
in seiner rede verteidigte er die
polizei gegen rassismus vorwürfe in
einem von demokraten regierten land gebe
es keine sicherheit sagte er
wie fanatisch wie grausam rassismus sein
kann das zeigt auch eine tat die vor
eineinhalb jahren die welt schockierte
in der neuseeländischen stadt
christchurch erschoss ein
rechtsextremist 51 menschen in zwei
moscheen seine tat übertrug er live ins
internet und zog damit wohl auch
nachahmer an etwa den attentäter von
halle das urteil heute in neuseeland
nahmen viele opfer und angehörige mit
einer art erleichterung auf normen
odenthal berichtet der mann der so
unfassbar brutal war der so viel unglück
brachte der niemals reue zeigte bekommt
heute seine strafe die höchste die es in
neuseeland gibt für jede der 51
mordanklagen von 1 bis 51 verurteile ich
sie zu lebenslanger haft ohne die
möglichkeit auf vorzeitige entlassung
15 märz 2009 10 prescott angetrieben von
einer kruden ideologie rechtsextrem
rassistisch stürmt der attentäter zwei
moscheen schwer bewaffnet schießt mordet
erschüttert die stadt das land die ganze
welt ich war in der moschee um mich
verletzte sterbende tote ich hielte
einen kleinen jungen im arm betete er
möge leben aber eher starten
du hast ihn genommen er war 3 das
monster hat man ein vater ermordet und
viele andere wunderbare sälen für mich
ist er nur ein erbärmlicher von trauer
und wut der wunsch nach gerechtigkeit
bei manchen nach vergeltung auf all das
antwortet die justiz mit ihren mitteln
so ein verbrechen hat neuseeland nie
zuvor erlebt und so ein urteil und
strafmaß ebenfalls nie zuvor
aber es stimmt ich habe mit
erleichterung aufgenommen dass dieser
mensch niemals mehr auf freiem fuß sein
wird der tag brachte gewissheit und
selbstgewissheit eine tat die hass säen
sollte lässt das land zusammen rücken
zurück nach deutschland eine muslimin
die sich als lehrerin bewirkt darf nicht
pauschal wegen ihres kopftuchs
abgewiesen werden
das hat soeben das bundesarbeitsgericht
entschieden die berlinerin wollte ihr
kopftuch im unterricht tragen und wurde
von der schulverwaltung nicht
eingestellt deshalb bekommt sie jetzt
eine entschädigung bisher hat das
berliner neutralitätsgebot das tragen
von religiösen symbolen im öffentlichen
dienst verboten
und jetzt geht es hoch hinaus und zwar
auf 2962 meter rauf auf die zugspitze
deutschlands höchstem berg heute vor
genau 200 jahren wurde dieser
nachweislich zum ersten mal bestiegen
der gipfelsturm damals kaum vorstellbar
ist heute durch seilbahnen nur noch eine
sache von wenigen minuten das hat folgen
an der einst einsamen spitze tummeln
sich jetzt massen von touristen claudia
vogel
er sind viele mindestens 700 bergsteiger
waren im durchschnitt pro tag von tal
auf die zugspitze zu spitzenzeiten sind
es über 4.000 so der deutsche
alpenverein
dazu kommen noch besucher die mit den
bahnen nach oben fahren obwohl derzeit
pro tag nur 3000 menschen ein ticket
lösen dürfen wird es oben eng
die frage ist nur wie alimentiert
limitiert wer darf darauf dass muss eine
gesellschaftliche diskussion werden die
der alten freien lenken steuern
anschieben kann aber es wird niemals
eine institution geben die für sich
sagen kann
ihr dürft und ihr dürft nicht vor 200
jahren machte er sich einen namen mit
der erstbesteigung der zugspitze josef
voß hatte den auftrag den berg und die
grenzregion zwischen bayern und
österreich zu vermessen seitdem haben
sich die natur und der berg verändert
die gletscher verlieren massiv an masse
und umfang also das ganze zugspitzplatt
hatte einen großen gletscher und heute
sehen wir da die relativ kümmerlichen
reste hinter uns der flächenverlust ist
enorm der schneeferner war vor 200
jahren noch 400 hektar groß heute sind
davon nur noch zehn prozent übrig diese
wanderer sind auf der jubiläums route
unterwegs der gipfel ist ihr ziel ein
ziel dass zur hauptsaison viele im blick
haben da schreckt die bergsteiger nicht
ab und blendet doch sehr aus und hat
einen herrlichen blick gerade am grat in
beide richtungen
es ist super die zugspitze ist ein
hotspot hier in bayern in deutschland
und ich glaube jeder hat das recht auch
einmal auf die zugspitze zu gehen sich
am gipfel zu feiern liegt im trend doch
deutschlands höchster berg kommt
allmählich an seine grenzen
republik noch mal in die usa dort ist
hurrikan laura in der nacht mit
windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 240
kilometern pro stunde auf die südküste
getroffen in texas und louisiana
zerstörte der sturm häuser ein mensch
kam ums leben zwei hat sich der hurrikan
etwas abgeschwächt doch meteorologen
warnen weiter vor extremen winden und
einer lebensbedrohlichen sturmflut
und jetzt bist du dran hält mit der
champions league und da gibt es am
sonntag ein super endspiel denn dann
treffen zum dritten mal im finale der
vfl wolfsburg und olympique lyon
aufeinander
der titelverteidiger aus frankreich
setzte sich gestern abend im halbfinale
gegen paris st germain knapp mit 1 0
durch
leo mit der deutschen nationalspielerin
dzsenifer marozsán hat zuletzt 2013 ein
endspiel verloren und zwar gegen
wolfsburg das halbfinale hart umkämpft
diese aktion von gero in der 66 minute
folgenschwer für paris platzverweis nach
gelb rot und freistoß für lyon
leos kapitän in rehna mit köpfchen das 1
zu 0 1 meter 87 körperlänge gekonnt
eingesetzt knapp zehn minuten später
erneut gelb rot aber dieses mal auf der
anderen seite lyon stürmerin nikita
paris ist nun im finale am sonntag zum
zuschauen verdammt die bundeskanzlerin
die länderchefs haben sich heute darauf
verständigt wegen corona bis ende
oktober keine zuschauer in
fußballstadien dazu der geschäftsführer
des ersten fc köln alexander verl
ich hätte mir natürlich gewünscht dass
er mitte september bereits starten
können die lokalen behörden haben die
concepta ich als tragfähig eingestuft
wir sind aber gut beraten gemeinsam mit
der politik in weg zu finden und dann
mit zuschauern wieder zu starten
zum tennis da ist jan lennard struff in
seinem allerersten viertelfinale bei
einem atp 1000 turnier ausgeschieden
sein gegner gestern abend in new york
eine nummer zu groß nämlich die nummer
eins der weltrangliste novak djokovic
steht nicht umsonst an der spitze der
tenniswelt der serbe auch in diesem jahr
eine klasse für sich
gegen jahns strophen wild musste der
joker jedoch gar nicht sein bestes
tennis zeigen
der deutsche mit nur wenigen gelungenen
aktionen im gesamten spiel dem 30
jährigen fehlte einfach die konstanz vor
allem der aufschlag machte struff zu
schaffen nur 40 prozent des ersten
service im feld zu wenig um den serben
in bedrängnis zu bringen
stross spiel nicht auf dem niveau was er
zu leisten imstande ist
am ende unterliegt er der nummer eins
der welt mit 6 0 1 6 im halbfinale
wartet jetzt der spanier aber auch beim
tennis oder york wurden heute aus
protest gegen rassismus und
polizeigewalt alle begegnungen abgesagt
noch zum wetter in der nacht ist neuer
regen unterwegs und morgen kommen
gewitter die details dazu hat gleich
osten terry im heute-journal begrüßte
christian sievers um 10 und hier geht es
jetzt weiter mit dem zdf spezial zu den
corona beschlüssen
wir danken für ihr interesse wünschen
ihnen noch einen entspannten abend und
verabschieden uns bis morgen wenn sie
mir
[Musik]
ein schulamt und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter hätten laura fotografiert von der
weltraumstation iss
und dieser sturm hat sich ja rapide
intensiviert weil es über den sehr
warmen golf gezogen ist und ist eine
lousiana an land gegangen
es ist seit 1856 der stärkste sturm der
dort tatsächlich an gelandet ist
andere stürmer bei uns in deutschland
sind bereits abgezogen zb sturm kirsten
hier sehen sie es nur auf dem bild wie
es verschwindet und das nächste tiefe
erreicht das erreichte uns ist aber kein
sturmtiefs bringt in der nacht regen vor
allem von westen her ansonsten ist es im
osten und im süden trocken mit
temperaturen zwischen 9 und 16 grad als
tiefster winter die von südwesten her
aufziehen aber auch im norden gewittert
es sonst auch mal trockene abschnitte
mit temperaturen bis 26 grad im südosten
deutschlands 25 grad an der neiße
17 sind es in schleswig holstein die
nächsten tage viel regen am alpenrand
bei 14 bis 24 grad einigen schauern im
norden ja und erregend der setzt sich
dann am sonntag im süden weiter fort ein
schöner abend